with reaction former senior counsel to
president trump author of the book
number one new york times bestseller
here's the deal kellyanne conway along
with former white house chief of staff
reince priebus kellyanne it's simple um
i paid my student loan back and i didn't
even get to finish college because i ran
out of money
every house i've ever purchased i use my
own money and i've been working two
full-time jobs my entire adult life so
giving free money to people in the form
of a house or in the form of loan
forgiveness is not something i quite
comprehend
it's not fair to the welders the
carpenters the hairdressers the people
who chose to not go to college or who
couldn't afford to go or to stay into
college not fair for them it's also not
fair to the people who have paid off
their student loans because they've made
personal financial sacrifices to allow
them to do that
it also is a complete farce that they
already passed something misnamed as the
inflation reduction act and turn around
and are going to make inflation worse
economist obama economist larry summers
and others are making this point sean
that you're going to make education more
expensive
by letting these colleges know that oh
gee every student basically has an extra
10 000 let's just tack it on from the
beginning but in addition to that
we are we are making things more
expensive because they continue to spend
money that we don't have on things that
we don't need and let me just conclude
with this
i'm hopping mad that we have an entire
political party in this country the
democrats who don't believe in investing
in dec
into opportunity scholarships school
choice charter schools educational
freedom that entire party john fetterman
is against it tim ryan's against it
raphael warnock's against it
they're all against it if you want to
invest in education let's front load it
into these kids who have been suffering
under biden's policies for two years
screen time is school time if he really
cared about funding education he would
make sure these kids with the lost
learning
mental health and emotional
lack of growth as they're telling adults
in their lives he would be doing that
there instead of trying to buy votes for
doctors lawyers and mba holders who are
in their 40s somehow getting student
loan forgiveness now it's outrageous
help our kids they need it
right and by the way the people that
paid their student loans the people that
pay their mortgages every month it's
their money that's going to go to other
people for free um right right
your reaction all of that but more than
that this phenomenon democrats now are
trying in their ads and on the stump to
sound like they are conservative and
they don't want joe biden to campaign
for them why would that be
well maybe because he's got the lowest
approval rating in the modern history of
american presidents only 20 percent of
democrats strongly support this
president he's an albatross around their
neck but you know what jude and
kellyanne we're talking about it's a
hundred percent correct here's the
problem these democrats don't believe in
the concept of america they believe that
they're more capable of spending your
money than you are it's back to the that
classic margaret thatcher line which is
the problem with socialism is that
eventually you run out of spending other
people's money and you hit all the
you hit all the numbers on the bingo
card inflation uh you know it's it's
obviously going to encourage more
borrowing kellyanne is correct the poor
people that decided not to go to school
the irony of thou i'm going to pay for
the people that did go to school
couldn't afford it borrowed the money
and can't pay it back
is amazing and it is an election gimmick
and 60
of the people here are wealthy people
that are going to get this money and 48
of those people are grad students just
like all the journalists out there that
have no problem with this new executive
order
or whatever joe biden's going to do to
pay off their loans too they're all
profiting off of this off of other
people's money it's wrong it's not
american and and what margaret thatcher
said so many years ago is actually
starting to come true before our very
eyes
you know reince thank you and kellyanne
thank you uh in my last book by the way
for the audience sake we appreciate you
guys being with us um i wrote in live
free or die socialism and its history of
failure whatever name is given whatever
form it takes whatever manifestation it
is it always results in the same thing
unfulfilled promises more poverty and
then at the end of the day you got to
calculate how much of your freedom you
gave up in the name of false security
given to you by your government you know
the people that said keep your doctor uh
keep your plan and save money those
people all right and there's ones that
said oh it's not a recession oh it's
transitory hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else